In the name of the Father, and of the Son, and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 29, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostles
Jason and Sosipater.
On the 29th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Apostles Jason and Sosipater
and their companions, the seven robbers, and Kerkirah, daughter of King Kerkilian.
St. Jason was from Tarsus, St. Paul's birthplace, but it was in Thessalonica that he met the
Apostle, offering hospitality to him and Silas.
When the Jews, under the sway of jealousy, rose up against the Apostle, they could not find
St. Paul and seized hold of Jason, dragging him before the polytarch and accusing him of
giving shelter to men who were rebelling against Caesar.
Once freed, he followed Paul on his missions to Macedonia and Asia, in company with other
disciples, including Sosipater, or Sopater, who came from Achaea, Peloponnese.
The two fellow disciples were linked in such spiritual attachment to their teacher that
St. Paul, riding to the Romans, greets them as his kinsmen.
He confided the government of the church in Tarsus to Jason, and that in Econium to Sosipater.
After having confirmed the foundations of Christianity in these churches, the two Apostles left for
the West to preach the good news there, arriving on the island of Korgfu, Kerkirah, or Korkirah.
They began by building a church dedicated to the Holy Protomarder, Stephen.
Even more than preaching by the demonstration of human wisdom, they addressed unceasing hymns
to the glory of God, and thus attracted a great number of pagans to the Orthodox faith,
that is, the right glorifying of God.
The success attained by the Apostles, disquieted Kerkirah, the king of the island, who had them
brought before him, intending to force them to sacrifice to the gods.
The saints replied to him, do what it seems right to you to do with our bodies, but you
have no power over our souls, because they belong to God.
Born into prison to await sentence, they found their seven robbers, Satorininos, Yakiscolos,
Faustian, Januarios, Marsalios, Efrasios, and Mamus.
By the example of their patience under trial and their words of eternal life, they converted
the robbers to the true faith, and also the Jailer Antony, who had been drawn by the fragrance
and divine light that permeated the dungeon.
When the soldiers who had been sent by the king to seize the new converts went into the prison,
they were astonished to see Antony sitting there peacefully, with a radiant being beside him,
holding across in one hand, and a sword in the other.
The other detainees were, for their part, wearing golden crowns, and the hymn of victory
resounded in the prison.
Holy, holy, Lord of Sabaoth.
The king had Antony brought before him, and asked him why he had thus abandoned the religion
of his fathers.
As his only reply the latter traced the sign of the cross on the monarch's face, who
beside himself with fury had his hand cut off.
Anthoned by an angel, the martyr continued inflexible and full of courage.
At his prayer, God raised such a violent storm that it threw the king's wife and two sons
to the ground.
Gert Killian, however, remained as stony-hearted as ever, and attempted to raise his hand against
Antony, but it was suddenly paralyzed.
He then ordered that Christ's disciples be beheaded outside the town.
After the execution, several devout Christians who had been present took Antony's body and
buried it in St. Stephen's church.
Two days later, Gert Killian summoned Jason and Sosipatha.
They confessed with one voice the one God in three persons, and far from being terrified
at the news of Antony's execution, gave glory to God, who had given him the patience and
courage to claim the crown of incorruptibility.
The king then proposed that they compete against one of his magicians, who had in one hour
made corn sprout and transformed into a warm loaf.
When this sorcerer began his magic incantations, the wild beasts in the surroundings and nature
itself began an abnormal agitation.
All those present were astounded at such power, except for the holy apostles, who invoking
the name of the Lord, caused the magician to die on the spot, creating its natural order
once more at the same moment.
The crowd then cried out, yes, the God of Jason and Sosipatha is truly the only God
God.
The furious sovereign had the saints thrown into prison and commanded that Satorninos be
brought before him.
The next day, having passed the whole night in prayer, the seven robbers were taken, loaded
down with chains before Karpian the prefect, no longer as common prisoners, but as Christians.
Now they were being questioned, Kerkira, the king's fifteen-year-old daughter, saw this,
and rushed to the window of the palace.
Learning that these men were being tortured for the name of Christ, she cried out, I too
am a Christian and reject the worship of idols to be espoused to Christ.
The king was at first astounded at his daughter's conversion, but once he had come to himself,
he tried to persuade her to renounce this faith that would bring her torture and death.
But his efforts were in vain.
During the period that Kerkilian allowed himself to reflect on the decision he must make, Kerkira
gave her jewelry away to the poor, and prepared herself with enthusiasm for the conflicts
of martyrdom.
She was delivered over to the soldiers who dragged her, heavily fettered, to a village where
Karpian the prefect put her to torture.
As her blood flowed down, the saint thanked Christ, allowed, for having thus given her baptism
in her own blood.
She refused every offer of marriage, saying that she had an immortal spouse in heaven, and
that nothing could attract her to the corruption of earthly life and idolatry.
She was thrown into prison on the king's orders, and he sent a terrible and brutal Ethiopian
soldier to do violence to her.
But by the power of God, a bear came and kept guard at the entrance of the prison, and roared
at the man when he arrived.
The saint stopped the beast with her voice and converted the Ethiopian whom she named Pristodolos.
She then sent him away in peace, giving him a cross, and advising him to reply to his
questioners, it is Christ whom I seek, it is He whom I love and worship.
The man went to the town, and did just this.
He was immediately arrested and put to torture, and finally cut into with a cleave by the
prefect's own hand.
After Christodolos' execution, Karpian went to the prison, but the bear barred his way.
Feeding a retreat, he asked the king's authorization to have done with the matter, and he set
fire to the prison.
The bear escaped, and hid in the forest while Kirkida, protected by God's grace, remained
in prayer in the midst of the flames, like the three young men of old, in the Babylonian
furnace.
After three days, the fire having been put out, the king went there to bury his daughter's
remains.
Imagine his surprise to discover in the middle of the charred debris, the radiant saint sitting
under the protection of a resplendent angel.
Insensible to Kirkida's reproaches, Kirkilian had her taken out of the town, when she was
hanged head downwards, and pierced to death, with arrows.
They then lay hold of saturninos and his companions, and through them into cauldrons, full of boiling
pitch.
At the moment at which they committed their souls into God's hands, they praised him for
having pity on them, as he had, on the good thief.
When the king learned that this execution had brought a great many conversions in its train,
and that the new Christians had buried the holy martyrs in a temple that they had quickly
cleared of its idols, he ordered that their remains be burned, and the ashes scattered.
But when he arrived with his soldiers, a terrifying dragon put them to flight.
The king began to pursue the converts who had fled to an island, but was drowned in the
waves, along with his entire army, as Pharaoh was of old, in the Red Sea.
The holy apostles were then freed, and were successful through their preaching, and confirming
the new Christians in the faith.
But this truce lasted only a short time.
The new Sovereign, Decian, had them arrested again, and ordered that Sosepatha to be thrown
into a barrel of burning tar.
The saint got into it, making the sign of the cross, and generously offered himself as
a sacrifice with a sweet fragrance before God.
The flames spread all around, burning many of the pagans who were present at the execution.
The terrified king threw himself to the ground, asked the God of Sosepatha for forgiveness,
and put himself under Jason for instruction in the faith.
After having given Sosepatha a solemn burial, Jason called back those of the faithful who
had taken refuge in the island, and baptized the king, giving him the name Sebastian.
Along with him, he baptized all the inhabitants who had been converted through the miracles
that were worked in those days.
Ever since that time, the island of Kordfu has, and spite of wars and foreign occupation,
remained a citadel of the true faith.
They destroyed all the idols there, and built churches, especially a great church, dedicated
to St. Kerkida, beside which kings Sebastian settled, to lead the ascetic life.
After the king's death, St. Jason restored the young crown prince to life, and worked
many miracles, until the day when he heard a heavenly voice calling him to join Sosepatha
in the kingdom of heaven.
He made ready his tomb near that of his spiritual brother, and having left his last instructions,
fell asleep on the 29th of April, at the age of 60.
As the centuries rolled on, the two holy apostles remained the faithful protectors and intercessors
before God of all the inhabitants of Kordfu.
After the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.